one of the fun scenes that I enjoyed
doing the most for sound was actually
the Maserati time trial I can't remember
if it was fully in the script like that
where we were cutting backwards and
forwards to the church with the moite
going back onto the Maserati the beauty
of that with the rawness of the engine
the gorgeous vocal the gorgeous singing
and then of course we introduced all the
fun of the stopwatches they were at
church but really they were listening to
they heard the gun go off for the
beginning of the time trial and they all
switched their watches on and that was
such a great sort of Jos of all those
different sounds it was defin one of the
most fun things to
do